on the streets of Hong Kong tonight
protestors barricade and set fire to the
entrance of an underground station and
in particularly distressing scenes a man
believed to be a plainclothes policeman
is beaten and then hit by a petrol bomb
he drops his gun in his escape and seems
dazed and confused' before racing to
recover it from a protester earlier even
as the government was announcing the new
emergency powers the protesters were out
on the streets angry and defiant fire
soon burning and hiding their identities
in a way they fear now they will not be
able to do the government is trying to
use this ban of masks to stop our
protest like hog boys becoming a police
state the beleaguered chief executive
Carrie Lam told a packed news conference
the violence was destroying Hong Kong
but she denied this was an authoritarian
move we are not claiming that Hong Kong
is entering a state of emergency but we
are indeed in an occasion of serious
danger it's clear that two things could
help defuse this situation one is that
you launch an independent inquiry into
how the police are dealing with these
protests and two you're stepping down
your resignation my question is are
either of those things going to happen
stepping down is not something that will
help the situation Hong Kong is now in a
very critical state or public danger and
I and my principle officials will try
our very best to return calmness and
order to Hong Kong society I think we
all have our own hypothesis for the
escalating violence that has taken place
on the streets of Hong Kong ironically
the powers being used against these
protesters are from colonial times used
by the British against leftist rioters
here with this move it's clear the Hong
Kong authorities feel they have no
alternative but to choose conference
and over compromise the risk of course
is that it makes everything here a whole
lot worse
Hong Kong is more divided and volatile
than ever and there is no end in sight